bon
la performance elle se définit comme une
réussite dans un domaine quelconque ou
l'accomplissement d'une tâche difficile
dans le domaine du sport la performance
c'est d'abord la victoire contre
soi-même ou contre un adversaire ou bien
la réussite à progresser
au quotidien j'accompagne des athlètes
de haut niveau dont la seule
interrogation c'est justement de
réaliser un jour en général un jour
programmé une performance est la
question qui m'anime c'est donc comment
faire pour faire émerger cette
performance
cette question a l'air intéressante à
mon sens puisque la performance on a
tous besoin et on est tous un jour
confronté à cette idée
le tableau que vous allez voir
apparaître
il fait écho à deux performances
majeures du sport la première c'est la
victoire de florent manaudou sur 50 m
nage libre à londres en 2012 qui lui
permet de devenir champion olympique et
la deuxième c'est le 100 m du chêne bolt
qui lui permet d'établir le record du
monde ce tableau décrit objectivement
comment ils s'y sont pris pour réaliser
ces performances
l'objectif de ces analyses c'est de
tirer des outils scientifiques
permettant de reproduire le plus
fidèlement du monde une performance
ce que cherche à travers sa les
scientifiques du sport c'est la recette
qui permet d'atteindre la réussite
ce type de tableau ce type de données on
le retrouve dans tous les sports avec
des données de puissance des données de
fréquence cardiaque
mais toutes sont tirés d'un même modèle
de la performance qui est un modèle
systémique un modèle qui considère que
la réussite c'est une combinaison de
plusieurs facteurs
et que pour faire émerger cette réussite
il faut essayer d'améliorer chacun de
ces facteurs ce modèle systémique on
pourrait le comparer à un robot un robot
qui pour devenir plus performant devrait
voir chacun de ses composants améliorés
pour un entraîneur ces différents
composants ce sont en fait les
différentes qualités qui font un être
humain la force la vitesse l'endurance
les aspects énergétiques les aspects
biomécaniques
en tant qu'entraîneur il a bien fallu
que je me confronte à ce modèle qui est
celui qu'on m'a enseignées
et comme je suis un peu compétiteur j'ai
voulu essayer de devenir meilleurs et
pour cela j'ai étudié chacun de ces
systèmes je les ai étudié de manière
relativement autodidacte en lisant en
allant sur internet en formant j'ai été
jusqu'à passer un master entraînement en
validation des acquis de l'expérience
afin de me convaincre que j'avais
atteint un niveau d'expertisé suffisant
dans ces différents domaines
et je me suis rendu compte que plus je
comprenais le fonctionnement de ces
systèmes que j'avais beau creuser il me
manquait toujours quelque chose
ce quelque chose peut-être que vous
l'avez perdue quand j'ai comparé le
modèle de la performance à un robot
en effet ce qu'il manque dans ce modèle
c'est l'être humain c'est l'individu
parce que moi chaque jour j'étais
confronté à des sportifs qui étaient des
personnes je n'étais pas confrontés à
des robots que je devais améliorer
l'autre point c'est que lorsque je
regarde une performance sportive lorsque
l'on regarde une performance sportive on
ne s'interroge pas sur le nombre de
foulées qui ont été réalisées ou sur la
fréquence mais on est attentif plutôt à
l'aise en ce que dégage le sportif au
sentiment de maîtrise totale a
l'impression de facilité que ça dégage
j'ai fini par comprendre ce qui me
gênait ce qui me gênait c'est que toutes
les observations que l'on fait tout ce
qui permet de produire les sciences du
sport est réalisé à partir du résultat à
partir de ce qui a été réalisé par le
sportif de quelque chose que l'on peut
regarder mais ce résultat il ne dit
absolument rien du processus le
processus c'est ce qui a permis
d'atteindre le résultat c'est ce qui
s'est passé avant
pour comprendre ces trois choses là j'ai
utilisé j'ai été éclairées par trois
auteurs qui ne sont pas venus du monde
du sport le premier auteur celui qui
voyait en haut à droite a décrit ce
qu'on appelle la contingence la
contingence c'est le fait qu'une
situation de compétition c'est une
situation qui est toujours unique qui
est toujours différente ce qui veut dire
que le sportif lorsqu'il réalise une
performance il effectue un acte de
création il s'adapte il n'est pas en
train d'appliquer une recette il est en
train de construire à chaque instant sa
performance au regard des contraintes
auxquels il est exposé
le deuxième paramètre deuxième concept
il m'a été enseignée par emmanuel kant
évidemment pas personnellement mais à
travers la lecture difficile douloureuse
de ce qu'il a pu écrire emmanuel kant il
a expliqué la théorie de la connaissance
la théorie de la connaissance elle nous
dit qu'il est impossible de connaître un
objet ou un phénomène sans y avoir été
confrontés c'est à dire que je ne peux
pas raisonner je ne peux pas comprendre
quelque chose sans en faire une
expérience sensorielle sans le percevoir
et la deuxième chose qui va avec c'est
que la problème c'est que cette
perception est les personnels
donc si je ramène ça dans le monde du
sport ça veut dire qu'un athlète perçoit
forcément la situation de compétition à
sa manière et que cette manière de
l'apercevoir moi en tant qu'entraîneur
je n'y ai pas accès ça veut dire que je
dois expliquer quelque chose à quelqu'un
sans savoir ce que c'est
le troisième paramètre troisième concept
qui m'a permis de surmonter cette
difficulté et qui malgré son mât
simplifier la tâche c'est la découverte
de la théorie de la complexité qui a été
proposé par edgar morin sociologue et
cette théorie elle explique que
lorsqu'on observe un phénomène complexe
on a tendance à vouloir le réduire à une
seule de ses composantes pour pouvoir
l'étudier c'est ce que fait la silence
chaque jour lorsqu'on tu deviens un
phénomène on ne le regarde jamais dans
son entièreté c'est trop compliqué il y
a trop d'implications trop de
d'interdépendance on est obligé de
regarder seulement un élément si on
reprend le geste sportif si je veux
étudier la manière dont un sportif se
déplace je suis obligé de réduire cette
analyse à une analyse mécanique en
oubliant tout ce qu'il ya autour
mais moi en tant qu'entraîneur j'ai
l'athlète dans son entier j'ai l'athlète
dans toute cette complexité
et donc il est important de considérer
les liens que vont entretenir les
différentes parties les unes avec les
autres je disais que ça m'a simplifié la
tâche parce que finalement ça marche
dans les deux sens c'est à dire que si
l'athlète bouge alors tout fonctionne en
même temps et donc je peux solliciter
tous les éléments à la condition que la
situation dans laquelle je mets
l'athlète correspond à celle que je vise
cela va amener à développer un modèle
d'entraînement où le coeur du travail se
passe avant l'action elle se passe sur
ce que j'ai appelé l'intention
l'intention dans le schéma que vous
voyez apparaître c'est quelque chose qui
se situe en am c'est quelque chose qui
se situe avant
l'action de du sportif et l'action c'est
ce qui va entraîner le résultat j'ai une
action sur un environnement donné qui a
pour conséquence un résultat plutôt que
m'intéresser à l'action a demandé à
l'athlète de reproduire des modalités je
vais m'intéresser à ce qui se passe
avant l'intention saleh pour le coup pas
uniquement la volonté c'est tout ce qui
englobe la volonté c'est à dire tous les
éléments que je mets à ma disposition
pour prendre des décisions à voir une
intention ça n'est jamais neutre je n'ai
jamais eu une intention par hasard j'ai
toujours une attention parce que j'ai
une perception
je ressens quelque chose j'ai un vécu et
une fois que je mélange tout ça je me
dis que la meilleure décision à prendre
au regard de ce que je sais et de ce que
je sens c'est çà et là attention c'est
tout ça à la fois
voyez que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'une simple décision donc mon travail
aujourd'hui en tant qu'entraîneur ça
n'est plus de trouver la bonne recette
mon travail c'est d'émanciper l'athlète
de le rendre responsable de ses
intentions car vous l'avez vu tout à
l'heure il n'y a que lui qui peut
ressentir et il n'y a que lui qui peut
décider pour lui mais
aujourd'hui je considère que la
performance c'est un acte de création
c'est la conséquence d'un comportement
que l'athlète va choisir librement
d'avoir dans une situation donnée et que
mon travail c'est de le rendre
suffisamment libre pour qu'ils se
sentent autorisés à prendre les bonnes
décisions celle que lui va considérer
comme étant les plus pertinentes
dans la situation de l'est
de manière générale dans notre quotidien
si nous souhaitons créer qui nous
souhaitons performer il faut apprendre à
être à l'écouté des signaux à l'ecoute
de cet instinct parce que finalement
l'instinct ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'inné ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
apparaît par hasard l'instinct ça n'est
que la conséquence de décisions
extrêmement rapides que nous prenons
parce que nous nous appuyons sur ce que
nous ressentons parce que nous appuyons
sur nos expériences et que nous sommes
capables de faire le lien entre ces
différentes choses
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]